calling for members this is the
local government committee in
room four four four sergeants
please call the absent members
welcome to the local government
hearing just a few housekeeping
items go over before we start
we have three items on the
agenda today all measures
that are back for concurrence
vote because these bills are
significantly amended in the
Senate and no simply policy
committee as are the final
policy of these bills local
government committee hears
doesn't sign in order our
first bill to day is one of us
the new member date daily AB
four four eight and we'll call
the system was a quorum first
back where curry here agar
curry here Waldron water in
here blown cubby aero cubby
are here Gabriel Gabriel
hear Grayson Grayson here
lackey reverse reverse here
of a pal of healthcare okay
good afternoon Mr daily life
to begin thank you madam
chair I'm here with the
Anaheim city council member
Chris Murray and my lips
director David Miller -- this
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE ORANGE
COUNTY HOUSING FINANCE TRUST
WHICH IS A PUBLIC PRIVATE EFFORT
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS IN THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE.
THROUGH THE DEVELOPMENT OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT SHORTAGE OF
A PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
UNITS IN THE REGION.
ORANGE COUNTY THE COUNTY
GOVERNMENT AND ITS THIRTY FOUR
MEMBER CITIES NEED A SINGLE
PURPOSE JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
TO SERVE AS A CONVENER OF
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS AND
COLLABORATORS.
THIS WILL SERVE AS A VEHICLE FOR
ACCOMPLISHING THE OBJECTIVE OF
CONSTRUCTING APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED UNITS OF
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN THE
COUNTY.
WITH THE BILL --
AND IBM MADAM CHAIR I APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR
STAFF'S WORK ON THE SERVER.
BUT ON THIS BILL EVERY WILL BE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING YOUR AYE
VOTE AND SHARING MY TIME WITH
COUNCIL MEMBER CHRIS MURRAY.
COULDN'T HAVE AFTERNOON THANK
YOU GOOD EVENING OR EVEN GOOD
EVENING.
EVERYONE MADAM CHAIR AND ITS KEY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I KNOW
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY ON THE BELL.
AT MY NAME IS CHRIS MURRAY A
MEMBER THE ANAHEIM CITY COUNCIL
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE ACC R.
C. BOARD OF DIRECTORS THAT --
HELP TO SPONSOR THIS BILL I
WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLYMAN DAILY
AS WELL AS OUR ASSEMBLY WOMAN I
SILVA.
AND OTHERS IN THAT DELEGATION
WHO ARE HELPING US TO PROMOTE
THIS BILL THIS BILL IS TRULY
ABOUT HELPING US COME UP WITH A
FUNDING MECHANISM.
THAT WILL ALLOW CITIES AND THE
COUNTY AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR
INTERESTS TO COME TOGETHER
ORANGE COUNTY TO POOL OUR
RESOURCES AND TO COLLABORATE ON
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AS
WELL AS EXTREMELY LOW.
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH WE
NEED IN THIS S. R. REGION'S
EXPERIENCED A 54% INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF THOSE WHO ARE
HOMELESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
A ANAHEIM I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU THE CITY COUNCIL HAS
UNANIMOUSLY ENDORSE THIS BILL
ALONG WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER
CITIES.
I CAME UP HERE TODAY TO SHARE
WITH YOU OUR PERSONAL COMMITMENT
AS A CITY OUGHT TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH OUR FELLOW
CITIES AND THE COUNTY. TO REALLY
MOVE THE BALL AND TO HELP
PRODUCE TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
UNITS SO THAT WE CAN FIND A
PERMANENT SOLUTION TO THIS
HOMELESS CRISIS AND HOPEFULLY
CREATE A MODEL. FOR THE STATE
THAT OTHER COMMUNITIES COULD
FOLLOW WHEN AND USED TO HELP AND
ASSIST THOSE IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
SO WITHOUT I JUST I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR PATIENCE
AND NOW IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY AND
YOU HAVE A LOT MORE IN FRONT OF
YOU BUT WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT I BELIEVE BE ANNOUNCED
EARLIER TODAY.
BUT TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT UP THE SPILLED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MAKE CAMERA BEHALF CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU OTHERS
IN SUPPORT GOOD EVENING AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHERE A TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT?
KELSEY BURN BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
ORANGE COUNTY SPONSOR TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHERS.
SING THAN ANY IT UP IN
OPPOSITION.
SING NONE OF DO ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION TO STRIKE
AT ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY XIN YES.
SO I'M JUST TRYING TO YOU KNOW
BECAUSE I'M USE TO FINANCING IN
BONDS YOU KNOW HAVING BEEN A%
COUNCIL MEMBER BUT THIS IS
DIFFERENT.
SO.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE PAYING
BACK INVESTED IN THE AND
INVESTORS SPECIFIC RETURN JUST
REPAYMENT.
OF THAT PUT OUT TO BUILD THE
STRUCTURES THAT.
ORDER.
THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
SO HOW WOULD IT ACTUALLY HOPE
WE'RE WITH THE MONEY COME FROM
TO PAY BACK THE DEBT I MEAN THE
HOMELESS PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY CAN'T
PAY THERE MUST BE SOMEONE PAYING
INTO.
I'LL TAKE A QUICK WHACK AT IT IN
THEN ASK OF CHRIS MARINO WHO'S
FROM THE CITY OF ANAHEIM.
TO CHIME IN.
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE.
THE GOVERNMENT'S WHO WILL FORM
THE JPA --
IDEALLY UP TO THIRTY FOUR CITIES
WHICH ORANGE COUNTY HOUSE.
THE COUNTY GOVERNMENT THE THIRTY
FOUR CITIES AND PRIVATE SECTOR.
A PHILANTHROPIST IN ORANGE
COUNTY HAVE SIGNALED THEIR
INTENT TO INVEST FUNDS IN THE
EFFORT.
BUT THE EXACT PAY BACK MECHANISM
I'M NOT SURE.
OF THAT THAT'S ALL PUT TOGETHER
YET.
KELSEY BREWER DID A LOT OF THE
WORK TO PUT ALL THIS TOGETHER
SHE'S FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
ORANGE COUNTY CITIES.
LET ME GIVE UP COUNCILWOMAN
MURRAY A CHANCE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION AS WELL AND THEN MISS
BREWER.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT CREATING A
CENTRALIZED FUNDING MECHANISM SO
THAT WHEN CITIES AND CITIES WILL
BE ABLE TO OPT IN OR NOT BE
FORCED INTO A SO.
VERY OFTEN WITH PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WITH
EMERGENCY SHELTERS THERE IS A
FUNDING GAP THIS WILL HELP TO
CLOSE THAT GAP SIMPLICITY
HOUSING ENTITLED.
PROJECT BUT IS SHORT SOME LEVEL
OF FUNDING THAN THEY CAN APPLY
TO THE JPA AND IF IT MEETS ALL
THE PARAMETERS.
THEN THEY COULD SEEK THAT
FUNDING IT WILL.
IT'S LIMITED GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES FOR GENERAL CITY
SERVICES THAT COULD COME TO HEAR
IT WILL ALSO CREATE THAT
CENTRALIZE FUNDING POOL WERE
PRIVATE SECTOR INTERESTS CAN PUT
THEIR RESOURCES KNOWING THEY'RE
GOING TO CONSTRUCTIVE PROJECTS.
SO WILL BE ABLE TO GET MORE
CHARITABLE GIVING FROM ALL OF
OUR A BUSINESS COMMUNITY WHO
SIGNALED THEY WANT TO GET BEEN
GIVEN AND GENEROUSLY TO THE
SOUTH.
FOR HEALTH IF YOU WANT TO TALK
TO THIS TECHNICAL ENSURE.
I'M SO I THINK I'M THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND CHRIS COVERED IT VERY
VERY WHILE OUR INTENT HERE IS TO
BRING AND PRIVATE SECTOR DOLLARS
AND BETTER ALIGN THE THIRTY FOUR
CITIES IN ORANGE COUNTY TO GO IN
A COORDINATED EFFORT TO
SACRAMENTO. TO RECEIVE THE STATE
FUNDING THAT YOU ALL HAVE
GRACIOUSLY MADE AVAILABLE OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
PACIFIC EARLY ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION REGARDING BONDING IF IN
THE FUTURE THE COUNTY OR ANOTHER
CD WANTED TO CONTRACT A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS OVER A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF YEARS.
WE WANTED TO SET UP THE GP TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THOSE BARNABA
DOLLARS HOWEVER WHERE OVER IN
THE SENATE --
THEY HAD VERY SIMILAR QUESTIONS
AND WE CLEANED UP THAT LANGUAGE
TIGHTLY FROM A PREVIOUS VERSION
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE DOLLARS
ARE CONNECTED WE CAN'T JUST BOND
AGAINST NOTHING LAW AND THERE
HAS TO BE A STRONG FINANCE DREAM
WE'D BE ABLE TO PROVE --
ALSO SOLD MAYBE AS ARE THE BUT I
JUST THINK AS A BUSINESS PERSON.
INVESTING IN THAT.
WOULD THEY BE ABLE TO GET HOME
--
TAX BENEFITS HOME ANY CALL OF
THE IRS POSSIBLY YEAH.
POSSIBLY BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE A
GOOD INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO DO IT
--
THE OTHER QUESTION IS THE
SUPPORT OF PART OF THE HOUSING
WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT --
HOW WOULD THAT WOULD THAT BE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES IN A HOW IS
THAT FUNDED THROUGH THE SAME
BOND?
ARE AS AN OPERATIONAL BOND OR IS
IT.
A DIFFERENT POT OF MONEY A LEAD
KELSEY WHO DID MOST OF THE SITE
I WORK ON THE ANSWER.
JUST THAT IT IT WOULDN'T ALL BE
BOND FINANCING THE MANY CASES WE
HAVE FUNNY THAT SEE THERE'S
LOCAL STATE OR FEDERAL AND
THERE'S JUST A GAP THAT'S NOT A
100% THERE THIS WILL BE A PLACE
WHERE THE COUNTY CAN PULL.
ALL OF ITS RESOURCES AND I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW MANY --
WEALTHY INDIVIDUALS IN TO GIVE
TO THIS AS WELL WANT TO GIVE TO
HELP CREATE.
A SOLUTION FOR PARENTS SUPPORT
HOUSING THEY JUST DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY CAN GIVE THE DOLLARS
AND BE ASSURED THAT PROJECT WILL
DEVELOP AND SO.
IT WILL ALLOW US TO CAPTURE ALL
THOSE CABINET COUNTING A PRIVATE
CAPITAL DOLLARS AS WELL --
BUT THAT BEING SAID IT IT'S IT
IT PROVIDES BASICALLY A MENU OF
OPTIONS FOR CITIES TO PULL FROM
TO CREATE THESE PROJECTS BUT
THERE IS AN ONGOING EFFORT
BETWEEN ACC OF SEEING THE COUNTY
OF ORANGE TO ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
--
THAT THOSE TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS
WE'VE HOUSING UNITS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED THAT ARE NEEDED IN
ORANGE COUNTY.
ARE ALLOCATED IN A WAY THAT IS
TRULY DISPERSED ACROSS THE
COUNTY AND SO EVERY CITY HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH A C. CO SEE TO
PUT FOR THE NUMBER OF UNITS THEY
WILL COMMIT. TO BUILDING BUT WE
STILL HAVE A FUNDING GAP THAT
MANY CITIES ARE FACING
PARTICULAR SMALLER CITIES AND SO
THIS IS THAT POOL OF FUNDING
WITH VACANT APPEAL AND AND AND
GET THAT ASSISTANCE AND THEN THE
ONLY THING THAT I WOULD ADD TO
THAT SPECIFICALLY ON THE
SERVICES.
YOU WILL NOTICE AND THE LANGUAGE
THERE ARE NO REFERENCES TO
SERVICES NOT BECAUSE A BEFORE
FOUR EIGHT IS ALL ABOUT THE
CAPITAL CONSTRUCTION THE
PHYSICAL CONSTRUCTION A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
HOWEVER PERMITS PART OF HOUSING
DOES NOT WORK AND MUST
WRAPAROUND SERVICES ARE PRESENT.
AND SO OUR VISION FOR A BEFORE
FOR A IN THE HOUSING TRUST IS
THAT THOSE SERVICES WILL STILL
RESIDE WITH THE COUNTY THAT IS
THE COUNTIES CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO PROVIDE
THOSE SOCIAL SERVICES.
BUT THE CITIES HAVE THE LAND USE
AUTHORITY MISS CHRIS I AM VERY
ACUTELY POINTED OUT.
THE PROBLEM IS THE CITIES DON'T
HAVE THE FUNDING TO CLOSE THOSE
GAPS AB FOUR FOUR EIGHT IS ABOUT
A CAPITAL FINANCE PLAN TO CLOSE
THIS FINANCIAL GAPS OR WEAKENED
PROCRIT THE PHYSICAL
CONSTRUCTION.
A PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
IN PARTNERSHIP.
AND WORKING WITH.
EVEN FOR EXISTING EMERGENCY
SHELTERS THAT WE'VE BUILT OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WE'RE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE ON THE SOCIAL
SERVICE ASPECT.
THANK YOU.
FURTHER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE --
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
BECAUSE IS STIMULATED SOME VARIA
HELPFUL CONVERSATION THANKS
AGAIN.
THANK YOU US SOME EVERDID FOR
BRING THIS FLORIDA I WILL BE IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL TODAY --
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM CABALLERO.
CUMPLIR AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY AYE AYE
LACKEY AYE REVERSE.
REAVIS I'VE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL HIGH.
BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THINK.
ALRIGHT NEXT UP IS A ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN WELCOME
[inaudible]
AMERICAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY OUT GOOD
EVENING ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU ALL ENOUGH SHARE GOOD
EVENING TO YOU.
AND TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE BEFORE YOU
PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
IT'S A MEASURE THAT.
HIGH IS A DIFFERENT BILL ODDLY
ENOUGH A FOUR CITY IN MY
DISTRICT BERKELEY --
AND FOR CITY --
THE SAID NEIGHBOR --
FOR PLASTER COUNTY --
WHICH IS THAT.
SIMILARITY IN NATURE TO A THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW VOTERS IN
PLASTER COUNTY TO DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WANT TO INCREASE
TAXES. TO HELP IMPROVE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES.
OF THE BILL ALSO WOULD GIVE
VOTERS IN THE CITY OF BERKELEY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPROVE OF A
LOCAL TAX INCREASE. TO HELP
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND THE FUN
OTHER SERVICES BUT IF APPROVED
BY VOTERS IN PLASTER COUNTY THE
TAX WILL INCREASE BY NO MORE.
THAN 1% TO ADDRESS THE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES IN THE
COMMUNITY.
UP THIS BILL WILL GRANT LOCAL
CONTROL OVER TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS THAT PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES
THAT OPERATE IN THE AREA.
OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS GRANTED
SIMILAR TAX AUTHORITY.
IN THE PAST INCLUDING TO SEVERAL
COUNTIES.
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES ON
BEHALF OF THESE TWO COMMUNITIES
THAT SEEK TO IMPROVE.
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THEIR
CITIZENS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY A WITH ME
TODAY THROUGHOUT ADDITIONAL
EMPHASIS IS JILL CHOICE
REPRESENTING PLASTER COUNTY AND
NICKELODEON LUKA REPRESENTING
THE CITY OF BERKELEY
[inaudible]
WELCOME GENTLEMEN.
IT DIDN'T IN MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE MY NAME STILL
CHOICE THE PLASTIC COUNTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICE FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE CITY OF BERKELEY AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN FOR
INCLUDING.
AYE LANGUAGE WITHIN THEIR BELT.
BRIEFLY THE NORTH LAKE TAHOE
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WAS
CREATED IN THE MID NINETEEN
NINETIES BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. TO COMBINED
COMBINED PARTS OF TO
TRANSPORTATION DISTRICTS WITHIN
THE LAKE TAHOE BASIN.
PLUS A COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
DISTRICT AS WELL AS TRADE A
TAHOE REGIONAL PLANNING AGENCY.
IT WAS TO ALLOW FOR SALES TAX
INITIATIVE TO SUPPORT
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES WITHIN
THE REGION.
AND THAT'S REGION IS UNIQUE IN
PLASTIC COUNTY IN THAT IT'S A
DESTINATION COMMUNITY WITH A
FAIRLY LARGE AMOUNT OF TOURISM
AND AS SUCH TRANSPORTATION
DEMANDS ARE DIFFERENT.
PLUS A COUNTY IS LOOKING TO
REVISE THE LANGUAGE TO ALLOW
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY AND
EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF
TRANSPORTATION TO INCLUDE MULTI
MODAL FORMS OF TRANSIT SUCH AS
TRAILS.
AND BUSES.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS PLUS A
COUNTIES BEEN WORKING WITH MANY
COMMUNITY GROUPS TO EXPAND OUR
TRAIL NETWORK. TO INCLUDE
CONNECTIVITY IN THE NORTH LAKE
TAHOE BASIN ALL THE WAY TO
TRUCKEE AS WAS ACTIVELY
EXPANDING A TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES. TO INCREASE HEADWAYS
EXPANDING BUS ROUTES INCREASING
SHUTTLE SERVICE.
THE REVISED LANGUAGE WILL ALLOW
US TO CONTINUE ON THIS PATH
ADDRESS COMMUNITY NEEDS AS WELL
AS DEMANDS ON INFRASTRUCTURE
PLACED ON THE COMMUNITY THROUGH
VISITATION.
WE HAVE WE CURRENTLY HAVE
SUPPORT FOR MANY OF OUR LOCAL
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY INCLUDING THE NORTH
LAKE TAHOE RESORT ASSOCIATION.
AS WELL AS THE LOCAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE NICOLO DELUDE HERE
WE HAVE THE CITY OF BERKLEY WILL
BE VERY BRIEF ONE I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FALLS WITH
LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
AGAIN THIS IS ONLY TO INCREASE
THE CABIN IS NOT TO RAISE THE
TAXES OF VOTERS WILL GO OUT
NOVEMBER ON THIS ISSUE.
IF IT'S SUCCESSFUL THE MONEY
WILL GO TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS IN BERKELEY WHICH
WE'VE HAD A BIG UPTICK.
LOCAL POLICE HIRING TO BEEF UP
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT AND THEN
TO BEEF UP OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BECAUSE BERKELEY IS ONE
OF THE FEW CITIES THAT ACTUALLY
PROVIDES MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
SO THAT.
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S TIMES
STAFF TIME AND HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
TALK ABOUT AND SHARE THE MEMBERS
HAVE A LITTLE SALAS POTTER HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAHOE LINES IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE THINK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
GREAT THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT SING NINE THOSE IN
OPPOSITION
.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD EVENING
DAVID WILL FOOT THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL --
TODAY MEMBERS WERE OBVIOUSLY
CONCERNED ABOUT ANY
AUTHORIZATION AND AGAIN THIS IS
AN AUTHORIZATION AND NOT A TAX
INCREASES IT AS HAS BEEN STATED
IT DOES AUTHORIZED A TAX
INCREASE.
BUT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THESE
AUTHORIZATIONS AS WE HAVE BEEN
FOR A NUMBER YEARS NOW.
WORRY THIS TO BE APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND WHERE THE VOTERS
TO APPROVE THIS BERKELEY'S
OVERALL SALES TAX RATE WOULD BE
NINE POINT 75%.
THERE'S ONLY TWENTY FOUR
MUNICIPALITIES MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA 5% THAT
MUNICIPALITIES IN THE STATE.
THAT HAVE A SALES TAX THAT HIGH
OR HIGHER --
SO WERE OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED
WE'RE DEALING WITH THEIR
AGGRESSIVE TAX INCREASE THAT'S
APPROACHING 10% --
YOU KNOW HIGHER THAN A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA OR
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
AND MEMBERS ARE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT THIS MONEY IS GOING
TO BE USED.
FOR THERE IS NO GUARANTEE.
THAT THE FUNDING IN THIS BILL
WILL BE USED FOR HOMELESSNESS OR
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES AND
MEMBERS WE KNOW THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE OF THAT.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO GUARANTEE
THAT THIS MEASURE AUTHORIZES A
SPECIAL TAX.
IT COULD AUTHORIZE THE GENERAL
TAX.
OUR CONCERN WITH THESE TAX
AUTHORIZATIONS AS REUBEN CONCERN
WITH THEM FOR A NUMBER YEARS
IT'S THAT THE MONEY IS SIMPLY
GOING TO GO TO UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITIES.
THE CITY OF BERKELEY CURRENTLY
HAS HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS NOT UNLIKE OTHER CITIES
THAT ALL OF YOU REPRESENT.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF UNFUNDED PENSION LIABILITIES
IF IT'S A GENERAL TAX NOTHING
PROHIBITS THE MONEY FROM BEING
USED FOR THOSE PURPOSES --
AND NOT FOR THE ONE STATED IN
THE BILL OR BY THE AUTHOR SO FOR
THOSE I THINK VERY VALID REASONS
WE ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYA OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SING NEITHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SOME MEMBER CARILLO I JUST HAVE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE THE
JPA.
AND IT'S IT BASICALLY WAS
LOOKING TO SEE WHO WAS IN
SUPPORT --
OF THE BELL --
THIS IS THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE AND SO --
APPRECIATE THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
BUT NONE OF THEM SEND HIM
LETTERS OF SUPPORT IT THAT --
THERE AT LEAST NOT REFLECTED
HERE THERE WERE ANY CITIES.
THAT -- ARE
NOT PART OF THE JPA AND IF THAT
WAS PURPOSEFUL.
I JUST WASN'T SURE WITH THE AREA
THE DISTANCE WITH THIS IS THAT
THE JPA AND THAT.
TAHOE --
JUST SPEAKING OF THE NORTH LIKE
TALK TRANSPORTATION THIRTY
AREN'T THERE THE TO THE AREA
THAT WE'RE COVER AND THERE ARE
NO CITIES --
WITHIN THE WITHIN THAT --
AREA OKAY ON BUT WE DO HAVE A
LOCAL PUBLIC UTILITY DISTRICTS
ARE SUPPORTIVE SO THAT'S WHY
YOU'VE GOT THERE THERE THIS
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AS PART OF IT
CORRECT OKAY.
GOT IT OKAY AND I I WAS JUST
CONCERNED BECAUSE IT LOOKED
LIKE.
LIKE NO CITIES BUT WILL GET THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS BECAUSE THEY
LIKE US BETTER.
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THERE WAS AN OPPOSITION
THAT.
WAS.
WE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT TO THINK
IF.
BUT SUSAN WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE --
WE WILL.
PROJECTED CLOSE I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AND I LIKE TO THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND MISTER WOLF --
FROM THE HOWARD JARVISTAXES
THOSE ASIAN AND LIKE TO PUT YOUR
MIND AT REST THERE'S NOTHING
ABOUT THIS MEASURE.
ON THAT SPEAKS TO PENSION
LIABILITY --
THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT THIS
MEASURE THAT WOULD AND THERE'S
NO EVIDENCE THAT WOULD SUGGEST
THAT EITHER OF THESE ARM FINE
AND UPSTANDING JURISDICTIONS
WOULD DO ANYTHING OTHER.
THAN WHAT THEY'VE ASKED TO DO
THEIR FOR THEIR VOTERS
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR VOTERS TO
DECIDE IF THEY WISH TO TAX
THEMSELVES.
IN THE SAME WAY THAT MORE THAN A
DOZEN JURISDICTIONS HAVE ALREADY
DONE AND BEEN GIVEN THE SAME
WAIVER. TO DO SO ON BY THIS
LEGISLATURE WERE ASKING THAT
THERE BE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES
PROVIDED FOR THE CITY OF
BERKELEY AND FOR THE JPA THE
NORTH LAKE TAHOE AREA SO THEY
CONSERVE THEIR CITIZENS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND FILE
WILL BE SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY
I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR TAKING ON THE PLUS OR THE
LAKE TAHOE TRIP NORTH LAKE TAHOE
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
OF THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND I
KNOW SOME OF THE TAKES SOMEONE
SPECIAL TO GO AND HELP DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS SO.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE COURAGE
TO DO THAT SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR OKAY SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADWARE CURRY.
IF I AGUIAR-CURRY I WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM CABALLERO
CUMPLIR AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO RIVAS.
REAVIS AYE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL NO. FIVE THREE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY NEXT HAVE ITEM TO A. B. SIX
FIFTY SIX FIVE THREE I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
WELCOME.
WELCOME MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GOOD [inaudible]
EVENING.
I HAD MISTER COMING EVERYONE
THAT WORKED WITH AGAIN THANK YOU
MEN CHAIR SO IN THE MIDDLE RURAL
PART OF SANTA BARBARA COUNTY WE
HAVE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES WITH
ACCESS.
TO QUALITY HEALTH CARE AND
PARTICULARLY IN A TOWN CALLED
LOMPOC SLUM POKED OUT LOMPOC BY
THE WAY AND IT LOOKS LIKE BONTA.
BROUGH THE BILL THANK YOU.
IT'S IT'S SORT OF GEOGRAPHICALLY
ISOLATED IT'S FIFTY MILES FROM
COTTAGE HOSPITAL IN SANTA
BARBARA CITY IT'S FORTY PLUS
MILES SAMARIAN HOSPITAL.
IN SANTA MARIA IT'S SORT OF STE
WEDGED IN BETWEEN AN AIRFORCE
BASE IN A FEDERAL PRISON.
AND FOLKS THAT NEED A MEDICAL
CARE THERE HAVE A LONG DISTANCE
TO TRAVEL AND WE'RE LOOKING TO
HOPEFULLY TAKE A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION CHANGE THAT WITH
THIS BILL.
IT WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW THE LOMPOC
VALLEY HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
COLLABORATE WITH COTTAGE HEALTH
A NONPROFIT TO DEVELOP A JPA TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE
IN THE LONG POKE.
VALLEY HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
REGION WITH MS KATZ GOT TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU.
CALVET MOSS DISCOVERED IN LOMPOC
AB MEDICAL CENTER AND DISTRICT
THAT.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT I THINK
THE AUTHOR DID A FANTASTIC JOB
OF DESCRIBING WHAT THE GOAL HERE
IS AND HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF
YOUR GREAT OTHER ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OTHER THAN WHEN IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY WELL WE HAVE IT ON THE
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY --
SOME MEMBER GRAYSON IN THE
SECOND ROW OF SOME MEMBER
LACKEY.
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FOR WE KNOW HOW IN REAL
AREAS WE HAVE.
TO FEEL MORE CREATIVE ON HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
HEALTH CARE TO PEOPLE SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT FORWARD.
WHICH I TO CLOSE.
HER SPECWEB FOR NIGHT BUT THINK
AND TERRY CALLED.
THE MOTION IS CONCURRENT
SENTIMENT SENATE AMENDMENTS AND
RE REFER TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE.
ACT WE ARE CURRY AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CUBBY ARROW CABALLERO
AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REAVIS [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL I YOU BILLS OUT NINE ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS.
NOW WE JUST HAVE OUT ON SNOW SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM I THINK
YOU'RE THE ONLY HOUSE OUT ON
ITEM ONE A. B. FOUR FOUR EIGHT
BLOOM [inaudible]
BLOOM I ITEM.
TWO OUR ITEM THREE AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY THURMOND BLOOM
[inaudible]
ROOM I THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS CHURNED